Jetzt geht's aber los zum letzten Mal in diesem Jahr, zum letzten Mal in diesem Monat an einem Donnerstag ein Blue Moon und zum letzten Mal auch mit Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club, die ja immer am letzten Donnerstag hier das Radio übernehmen und machen, was sie wollen, glaube ich.
Oder?
Wir machen alles, was du sagst.
Ihr seid so lieb.
Vom Chaos Computer Club sind heute da Erdgeist, hallo und guten Abend.
Wunderschönen guten Abend.
THS.
Guten Tag.
Und Maha. Hallo. Und im Gegensatz zu normalerweise machen wir heute nicht ein Thema, was wir euch in aller Ausführlichkeit auswalzen, bis zum Ende, sondern einen kleinen Rückblick, denn wir haben ja ein Jahr gehabt, das die Nummer 2012 trägt. Ende des Jahres geht dann die Welt unter und davor ist noch viel Kram passiert, der so mit dem komischen Internet, von dem wir mal alle reden, zu tun haben, oder mit Computern oder mit dem Telefon, die in der Hosentasche ab. Und wir wollen mal gucken, was da so alles irgendwie am Start war. So, liebe Herren, wir hatten ja da ja möglicherweise die ein oder andere Urheberrechtsdebatte. Ja, ja, ich würde mal bei dem Thema anfangen wollen, dass das bei allen sozusagen am präsentesten ist, nämlich Musik. So frag ich mich, soll ich den Erdgeist zuerst fragen? Nein, das machen wir später. Mit dem Tracker das meine ich. Ist denn euch irgendwie das persönlich aufgetreten, angetreten, Verwandte abgemahnt worden, irgendwas mit der Musik passiert dieses Jahr? Also so Filesharing, Tauschbörsen mäßig?
Es ist ja so, du hast es gerade erläutert, also Trennung, Geheimdienst, Polizei, ganz klare Sache. Wieso gibt es denn auch eine Gerichtsverhandlung? Also was ist denn die Gegenargumentation? Beziehungsweise was steht denn da jetzt noch im Weg, dass das wieder verboten wird?
Na die Gegenargumentation ist natürlich halt wegen der Sicherheit. Also wir müssen ja was gegen die bösen Terroristen tun. Und dementsprechend müssen sich halt Polizisten und Geheimdienste austauschen, das ist halt das Argument. Und da ist natürlich ein Stück weit was dran. Es ist halt schon klar, dass dagegen natürlich auch Erkenntnisse auf der einen oder anderen Seite der Barrikade anfallen, die dann halt ermittelt werden sollten. Eigentlich ist die Art und Weise, wie das da passiert, halt sehr, wie sagt man, freihändig. Auch internationale Daten aus dieser Datei können durch auch internationalen Geheimdiensten oder Polizeibehörden geteilt werden. Und eines der Dinge, die wir halt da im Kern bemängelt haben, war auch, dass da immer so getan wurde, als würde es sich um eine Datei handeln, wo ein einzelner Beamter davor sitzt und dann mal einen Namen eingibt und dann irgendwie mal ein Aktenzeichen daraus bekommt, was dann bei einer anderen Behörde möglicherweise zu den Daten führt, die er sucht. In der Realität ist aber so, dass halt so ein polizeilicher Fahndungssoftware, die halt auch automatische Anfragen generieren kann und Daten in einer anderen Beziehung setzen kann und die eigentlich aus dem geheimdienstlichen Bereich kommt und auch bei den Geheimdiensten auch noch verwendet wird. In jedem Fall ist es auch für RS Case, dass die Schildstellerin diese Antiterror-Datei hat und das auch in den Prospekten der Hersteller angepriesen wird, dass sie genau diese Funktionalität hat. Dass man halt einfach diese Darstellung, dass der Beamte da nur mal gelegentlich ein Aktenzeichen heraus sucht, was er heute völlig falsch vor Gericht dargestellt hat. Die Verhandlung selber war nicht so interessant wie die sonstigen Verhandlungen von fastes Gericht. Aber mal gucken, das Urteil wird dann irgendwann nächstes Jahr kommen.
Hast du schon eine Tendenz, was du glaubst, was rauskommt?
Ich vermute mal aus der Verhandlung raus, dass sie die Antiterror-Datei einschränken werden. Dass sie sagen, okay, dieses und jenes geht nicht, diese Details müsste wieder löschen, diese Art und Weise des Vorgehens müsste löschen. Was auch unter anderem damit zu tun hat, dass die Behörden vor Gericht versucht haben, den Eindruck zu erwecken, dass sie sowieso den Rahmen des Gesetzes nicht ausschöpfen, sondern viel weniger tun, als sie eigentlich nach dem Gesetz dürften. Und in solchen Fällen hat das Verfassungsgerät eigentlich schon immer dazu tendiert zu sagen, dann schränken wir das Gesetz halt mal soweit ein auf das, was wir tatsächlich nachweislich eurer Arbeit brauchen, nicht der Ruhigenamt.
Was jetzt gerade interessant war, ist, du hast ja das Wort Hersteller in diesem Zusammenhang für die Software. Ich finde ja auch nochmal, das Thema ein bisschen aufzumachen, das 2012 das Jahr war, wo in der Öffentlichkeit eine viel größere Rolle gespielt hat, dass es für diese ganzen Sachen Hersteller gibt. Also Waffentechnologie, Spionage, Software, Fahndungsdatenbanken, glaubst du, das sozusagen gerückt jetzt immer mehr ins Licht der Öffentlichkeit?
Ja, das ist natürlich dadurch ins Licht der Öffentlichkeit gerückt, aber das ist halt besonders, dass in allen nordafrikanischen Ländern Akten gefunden wurden, auch von westlichen Herstellern, die da Spionage-Software und Drucksoftware geliefert haben. Und die Frage, was mit dieser Technologie ist, wieso es die überhaupt gibt und ob die nicht exportkontrolliert ist und welchen Regeln in der Nutzung dieser Technologie unterliegen sollte, dass die dadurch viel mehr in den Fokus gelangt ist. Und wir haben sich hier einen Teil dazu beigetragen, also auch der Kongress steht da dieses Jahr unter dem Motto Not My Department, was durchaus auch eine Anspielung und ein Hinweis darauf ist, zu sagen, okay, wer von Leuten aus den Eckers von der Arbeit eigentlich in solchen Firmen ist, das ist in Ordnung, was hat man da für eine moralische Beurteilung zu treffen und gibt es da nicht Alternativen dazu.
Kannst du schon in die Kristallkugel gucken und sagen, was da nächstes Jahr Thema sein wird in diesem Bereich?
Nicht wirklich, nein. Viel ist natürlich von News-Events getrieben, also wenn halt wieder Sachen aufgedeckt werden, wenn solche Software doch mal in der Öffentlichkeit analysiert wird. Klar ist jedenfalls, dass so die beiden großen Bereiche, Trojaner und die Packet-Inspection, durchaus wichtig bleiben werden, weil da doch eine Menge passiert und ich vermute mal möglicherweise auch Forensik-Software und halt so Fahndungs- und Geheimdienst-Software, die halt in dieser Datenvermaschung und Vernetzung ermöglichen, dass die noch nächstes Jahr durchaus wichtiger werden.
Na, der Bundesnachrichtendienst sucht ja immer noch, nein, der BKA sucht immer noch Leute, die ihn da in Bundesteuern anaprogrammieren. Auch jetzt bei öffentlicher Ausschreibung. Hat sich wohl bisher jemand gefunden, der darauf Lust hat?
Ja, das wäre eigentlich ein ganz gutes Zeichen, dass offensichtlich doch irgendwie Großvorteile der qualifizierten Menschen halt keine Lust haben, sich an solchen Entwicklungen zu beteiligen.
Nun gut, und wir werden dann möglicherweise nächstes Jahr dann auch wieder von dir erfahren, wo es da eine Gerichtsverhandlung gab. Frank, vielen Dank und viel Spaß noch. So, die großen Sachen, die heute hier im Minutentakt durchs Netz fliegen.
Du hast aber noch nicht erklärt, warum es Not My Department heißt.
Da wollte ich ja sozusagen warten bis sozusagen die Nachhalb 12, weil wir dann jetzt sagen, das große Kongress-Teasing aufmachen. Aber wie gesagt, machen wir später. Wir haben ja noch eine sehr, sehr, sehr lange Liste. Was haben wir denn jetzt noch hier? Der böse Wolf? Wieso steht denn der böse Wolf auf? Wer hat den bösen Wolf auf die Liste geschrieben?
Der kommt doch später.
Der kommt auch später? Was kommt denn dann jetzt?
Du bist doch normalerweise so aufgeräumt hier in diesen Sendungen.
EU-Datenschutzverordnung. Man bereitet die Sendung vor, alles sieht nach einer großen, großartigen Liste aus. Da können wir echt lange viel zu erzählen. Und dann steht ja sowas wie EU-Datenschutzverordnung sowie Richtlinie.
Herrlich.
Ja, weiß wieder keiner. Na gut. Schlangenkuchen. Das ist nochmal zurück zum Höhepaarrecht. Schlangenkuchen ist jetzt gerade die letzte große Abmahn-Geschichte. Es wird ja immer wieder, also jedes Jahr eigentlich geht es darum, dass irgendein Blogger abgemahnt wird, weil er irgendein Bild hingestellt hat, wo er keine Urheberrechte oder Verwertungsrechte dran hat. Und dann kommt irgendein Anwalt und sagt so nein, das darfst du nicht, hier zahl mir 1000 Euro. Und es gibt jetzt sozusagen, also in den letzten Monaten hat eine Firma von sich Reden gemacht, die immer mal wieder abmahnt. Die war dann auch mal im Gerede, weil sie angeblich von dem einen Foto gar nicht so wirklich die Nutzungsrechte hatte. Und dann jetzt taucht der Verdacht auf. Also man möge mich bitte sozusagen nicht festhalten. Also es taucht der Verdacht. Also es gibt Leute, die vermuten, es könnte so sein, dass die Firma Folgendes macht. Sie guckt im Netz, welche Bilder total viral verbreitet werden. Also zum Beispiel das von einer Schlange, die total echt aussieht, die in Wirklichkeit aber ein Kuchen ist. Und wenn dieses Bild richtig weit rumgegangen ist, dann geht sie zu der Frau oder dem Typen, der das Foto gemacht hat und sagt, du willst uns nicht vielleicht mal die Verwertungsrechte an dem Bild verkaufen. Und dann geht es hin und dann ist das Bild ja schon überall im Netz und mahnt all die Leute, die es im Netz verbreitet haben, ab. Guter Plan, oder? Sollte man das Thema unterbinden?
Also, naja, sich so ein Bild zu nehmen und irgendwo weiter zu verbreiten, wo die Urheberrechte nicht klar sind, ist halt immer mit einem gewissen Risiko verbunden. Da muss man... Ja, ist halt natürlich... Meine Sympathien für die Leute, die da zum Abmahnen rumgehen, sind da auch sehr, sehr im engen Rahmen. Aber wenn man so ein Bild nimmt, das viral verbreitet, dann muss man sich da immer mit... auseinandersetzen, wo es herkommt. Irgendwie muss man da ja, wie gesagt, wie ich vorhin andeutete, abwägen zwischen...
Es gibt halt sozusagen einen nicht geringen Anteil, vielleicht ist es auch ein geringer Anteil, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein lauter Anteil der deutschen Blogger, die sagen so, das geht so nicht weiter, weil so funktioniert das Netz. Das Netz funktioniert genauso, dass alles viral verbreitet wird. Das muss irgendwie gehen, das muss mal geändert werden.
Das Problem ist eigentlich eher, dass auf der anderen Seite das mit der Abmahnung da angegangen werden muss. Dass dieses Unwesen, also das ist eigentlich in Deutschland ziemlich eigen. Ich hab da mal, wo war denn das? Ach, in der Kimbell-Geschichte wurde ich ja befragt von der neuseeländischen Presse und dann hab ich den versucht zu erklären, dass Kimbell damals die Abmahnanwälte da mit dem Grafenreus zusammen eigentlich aus dem Boden gestampft hat. Und die kamen da mit diesem Konzept überhaupt nicht klar, dass so eine kostenpflichtige Abmahnung, wo dann die Gegenseite auch gleich noch Anwaltskosten und alles damit bezahlen muss, und wie dieses Konzept ist in Deutschland, ich weiß nicht, ob es weltweit einmalig ist, aber es ist sonst im Ausland ziemlich unbekannt. Und da muss man da glaube ich mal ran, dass das so für, naja, eigentlich Bagatellen irgendwie gleich Abmahnkosten in irgendeiner Größe aufzurufen, die da eine Industrie draus entstehen lassen, das ist da eigentlich das, woran es krankt. Das würde alles nicht passieren, wenn man da nicht beliebig Geld generieren könnte. Und ich glaube, das ist dann eher die Lösung, als auf der anderen Seite gleich zu sagen, man muss als irgendjemand, der ein Werk ins Netz gestellt hat, komplett alle seine Rechte daran aufgeben, bloß weil es sich gerade viral verbreitet.
Das ist ja auch der interessante Punkt, den man dieses Jahr auch lernen konnte, nicht die Leute, die sich mit Computer-Internet beschäftigen, sind automatisch dafür, dass es gar kein Urheberrecht mehr gibt. Wollt ihr noch mal über die Kulturwertmark reden eigentlich, fällt mir auf?
Naja, also ich denke, das ist nach wie vor ein wichtiges Konzept, vor allen Dingen. Und das ist das, was viele Leute nicht verstehen. Die Kulturwertmark ist ja auch sowas, was eben die Privatkopie auch langfristig sichern kann. Weil, naja, irgendwie muss es eine Vergütung geben. Und ich meine, das kann ja neben der Kulturwertmark...
Maha, von vorne. Kulturwertmark ist...
Na ja, es hängt damit zusammen, dass es eine Abgabe gibt auf den Internetanschluss. Und das soll aber jetzt nicht über irgendwelche Verteilungsgesellschaften verteilt werden, wie das jetzt schon der Fall ist. Es ist zwar nicht auf den Internetanschluss, aber auf Speichermedien gibt es bereits Abgaben. Da zahlen wir alle. Und dann gibt es halt Organisationen. Es gibt die sogenannte ZBY, die Zentralstelle für... Ach, ich weiß es gar nicht. Also jedenfalls, die sitzen bei der GEMA. Und die verteilen dann das eingenommene Geld. Und die Idee vom Chaos Computer Club ist, dass das sozusagen die Nutzer selber machen können. Dass sie halt selber eben solche Kultur, einen Kulturwertmarkt verteilen an Sachen, an Urheber, die sie gut finden und so. Dass das also dezentral ist und damit eben sehr datensparsam. Und das ist halt dann ein großer Vorteil. Und dadurch, dass es so etwas gibt, ist halt die Privatkopie sichergestellt. Denn das ist ja, dass in Deutschland gibt es halt die Möglichkeit der Privatkopie, weil es eben auch eine Abgabe dafür gibt. Und ohne die Abgabe wird auch die Privatkopie gefährdet sein. Die müssen wir natürlich auf jeden Fall sichern.
Jetzt ist ja die Kulturwertmarkt aber sozusagen ein Konzept, das ist relativ kompliziert zu erklären. Der Name ist sperrig, war die Kritik und, und, und, und. Es ist auch vom Club ja als Diskussionsgrundlage angekündigt worden. Also nicht als, ich müsste es jetzt genau so machen, sondern nur so, wir wollen nicht nur immer meckern, sondern wir wollen auch mal einen positiven Vorschlag machen. Gibt es denn jetzt eigentlich eine Diskussion? Also hat da noch mal irgendwie Weiterentwicklung stattgefunden oder steht das jetzt einfach nur so im Raum und man kann immer nur wieder hinzeigen und sagen, ja wir haben doch aber mal was gemacht?
Das kann man natürlich sowieso immer, aber wir hatten auch, na so was trägt halt meistens länger. Sowas muss man da in den wissenschaftlichen Diskurs einbringen, denn beschäftigen sich dort da Philosophen und Soziologen und Juristen da mit und die haben da immer so eine Vorwärmphase und da muss man dann, naja, denen muss man da erstmal so Gedankenputter hinwerfen und die übereilen auch nichts. Und mit denen hatten wir da so, eigentlich in auch so mäßiger Frequenz, aber hatten da auch gute Gespräche gehabt. Wohl gute Gespräche haben wir sich auch. Und generell wird dieses Konzept auch begrüßt und verstanden, weil es so die Entscheidung dort wieder aus den Gremien zurücknimmt und demokratisiert. Und wenn das allgegenwärtig ist, dass man auch ständig connected ist und ständig diese Kulturwertmarken vergeben kann, weiß nicht so Leute, die Flatter benutzen, so ein System, mit dem man im Internet Kleinstmengen spenden kann, an Dinge an Blogposts, an Tweets, an Software, die einem gefallen. Dieses Konzept funktioniert so leidlich. Man kann nicht davon leben, außer einige Ausnahmen, aber es kommt da schon so ein bisschen was bei rum und man fühlt sich natürlich immer geschmeichelt. Und das ist so eine auch institutionalisierte Art und Weise, jemanden anderen zu schmeicheln. Das ist schon so ein Zeichen, dass es ein Weg ist, der funktioniert. Und wenn man das dann am Ende dann auch noch juristisch irgendwie festklopft, dann glaube ich schon, dass da was draus werden kann. Für konkrete Hoffnung müsste man da selber, glaube ich, nochmal mit sich in den Arsch treten.
Doch, ich glaube, es besteht Hoffnung. Ich war ja selber auf einem Podium dabei in München beim Ministerium. Und da war eben auch einer von der ZBÜ im Publikum, der dann nachher zu mir gesagt hat, das würde ihm sofort einleuchten. Also das sei für ihn kein Problem. Während die rechte Vertreter, ich saß da mit lauter Lobbyisten, gut ich bin natürlich auch einer für den CCC, aber ich saß da mit lauter anderen Lobbyisten auf dem Podium, die haben gleich geschrien, ah nee, Kulturwerdenmarkt, wir wollen doch unsere Inhalte verkaufen, wir wollen nicht irgendwie, also die Privatkopie, nee, wir wollen halt mehr verkaufen. Und ich denke, da gibt es schon nochmal eine ganz interessante andere Front. Dass also plötzlich die Leute von der ZBÜ sagen, ja können wir was überlegen, und dann aber wieder die Urheber kommen und sagen, nicht die Urheber, das haben sie selber schon in die Falle getan. Also die rechte Verwerter, die sogenannten Leistungsschutzverträger, da sieht auch keiner mehr durch. die dann sagen, wir wollen ja irgendwie auch noch was verdienen. Also da gibt es dann schon nochmal ganz neue Koalitionen. Also von daher sehe ich das nicht ganz so pessimistisch.
Okay, also da kann noch was draus werden, aber es wird jetzt nicht wie die CD3S gleich im Januar losgehen. Apropos im Internet Dinge verkaufen, was ist eigentlich mit Bitcoins? Bitcoins waren, da hatten wir also schon länger her mal eine Sendung im Chaosradio drüber gemacht, eine, ich will jetzt nicht sagen virtuelle Währung, eine elektronische Währung. Also an Geld, das nur durch Umtauschkurs in Geld wie wir es kennen sozusagen einen Wert erhält und das sozusagen durch Rechenkraft berechnet wird. Das wurde sehr groß so 2011 und dann gab es so ein paar größere Skandale, wo halt irgendwie größere Mengen dieses Geldes des Bitcoins weggekommen sind. Und ich habe aber jetzt, soll ich mal sehen, das gibt es immer noch, oder? Gibt es einen Status?
Das gibt es immer noch. Unter dem Bekanntenkreis gibt es auch Leute, die da noch weiter Minor betreiben. Also diese Zahlen ausrechnen und dann Strom in Bitcoins verwandeln. Und es gibt auch Bürgerberatereien, mit denen man da bezahlen kann.
Naja, keine.
Also so der richtige große Durchbruch ist da bei Bitcoin noch nicht rausgekommen. Aber zu richtigen Neuigkeiten, außer so die negativen News, dass die Wallets weggekommen sind, habe ich auch nicht gehört.
Gibt es denn überhaupt irgendwas zu bezahlen im Netz? Neues, also so, dass man so Kleinstbeträge irgendwie mal weggeben kann oder sowas?
Die einzig spannende Geschichte, die ich jetzt so gesehen habe, ist, dass es total Mainstream wird, anonyme Kreditkarten sicher zu organisieren. Du kannst jetzt an die Tanke gehen, kannst dort Geld dalassen und bekommst eine Prepaid-Kreditkarte, auf die du Geld auch anonym einzahlen kannst. Das Einzige, was sie da sehen wollen, ist eine Mobiltelefonnummer, an die man eine SMS geschickt bekommt. Aber da es ja dabei Aldi Talk auch anonyme Prepaid-Mobilfunkkarten gibt, kann man sich da jetzt wirklich anonyme fürs Internet bezahlen, taugliche Visa-Karten klicken.
Die kann man tatsächlich sozusagen mit... Also gibt's wahrscheinlich auch von anderen Anbietern der Vollständigkeit halber?
Nee, das ist ja nicht von Visa. Ich glaube, dasselbe gibt's da wie auch im Mastercard von derselben Firma. Aber ich...
Es wird Zeit, dass das Jahr zu Ende geht, oder?
Welches Jahr?
So, also mit dem anonymen Betahlen, das wird erstmal Plastigeld. Was ist eigentlich, apropos Plastikarten, nächster Gedankensprung, was ist mit der kranken Dingens... Na hier, sag schon. Elektronische Gesundheitskarten. Elektronische Gesundheitskarten. Mir hat auch nicht meine Krankenkasse angerufen, hat gesagt so, Herr Richter, wir hatten Ihnen noch eine Mail geschrieben, dass Sie uns ein Foto schicken wollen. Ich habe keine Post bekommen. Gibt es irgendwie Neuigkeiten? Also Plan war ja so eine Chipkarte einzuführen, wo irgendwie die komplette Krankenakte drauf geht. Gibt es noch? Weiß das einer?
Naja, die Akte sollte ja nicht drauf sein, aber man sollte mit der Chipkarte Zugang zum Krankenakte haben. Das ist alles ein bisschen, hat sich alles ein bisschen verzögert. Offenbar ist das so eine Art, weiß ich nicht, Autobahn-Maut-Geschichte, die nicht so richtig in Gang kommt. Aber ich kenne den aktuellen Status nicht. Aber ich bin eigentlich ganz froh, wenn es nicht so schnell geht damit, weil das doch ein ziemliches Problem darstellt.
Ist das denn so, ist dann so Verschleppung sowas auch, wo man sagt, okay, naja, da haben sich am Anfang so Leute drüber gewehrt, lass uns mal einfach lange damit brauchen, das einzuführen, dann fällt es nicht so auf. Ist das politisch?
Ne, das glaube ich nicht. Also ich glaube wirklich, dass da viele, viele Firmen viel versprochen haben, was man nicht so schnell halten kann. So ähnlich wie bei den Zügen für die Deutsche Bahn.
Oder den Berliner Flughafen voll.
Oder die E-Mail.
Genau. Die E-Mail passt noch besser eigentlich.
Was ist denn damit eigentlich, die E-Mail? Da gab es noch den anderen Anbieter.
Keine Ahnung.
Also nur zur Erklärung, es gibt den Plan sozusagen, von der Post glaube ich und von der Telekom aus, dass man E-Mails schicken kann, die dann sicher unterschrieben sind, die dann pro, genau, der E-Postbrief, die dann pro Mail Geld kosten. Und auch sozusagen von der Verschlüsselung so her, dass sie nicht wirklich verschlüsselt sind, sondern man verschlüsselt sie, bis man sie zur Post gibt. Die darf das aufmachen und dann wird es nochmal verschlüsselt. Also totaler Quatsch gibt das mittlerweile oder ist das eingestampft worden?
Die machen da nur ganz groß Werbung. Ich war ja da erstaunt. Ich bin neulich an irgendeinen Browser geraten, ohne Adblock und da war gleich oben Prankte groß, ich glaube irgendein Fußballverein aus Bayern, hat da irgendwie auch gleich noch einen Werbevertrag mit denen. Ich weiß nicht mehr wie der hieß, Bayern München oder so. Und da wird gerade große Mengen Geld reingepumpt, wie es aussieht. Und ich hab da im Netz selber wenig von gehört.
Also falls, wir machen es einfach so, falls einer von euch einen E-Postbrief oder eine DND-E-Mail tatsächlich schon mal benutzt hat, kann er gerne anrufen. 0331 70 97 110. Und wir machen solange das Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Zum letzten Mal in diesem Jahr das Chaos Radio mit drei Gestalten aus dem Chaos Computer Club, nämlich Maha, THS und Erdgeist. Und wir werden gleich nochmal über den Kongress reden, der dieses Jahr auch wieder stattfindet. Die Frage, die ich vorhin noch habe, ist, die hier steht noch in dem Stichpunktzettel, Drohnen sind nun Alltag.
Also in den Vereinigten Staaten ist ja wohl grad gang und gäbe, dass der Krieg im Ausland nicht mehr mit Soldaten auf dem Boden geführt wird, sondern dass dort die Drohnen hin und her fliegen und Terror verbreiten, um dort die militärischen Ziele durchzusetzen. Und es scheint dort außer in einigen informierten Kreisen einfach total gang und gäbe zu sein, dass Drohnen jetzt so das Kriegsmittel der Wahl sind. Und wahrscheinlich wird sich das nur ändern, bis wenn dann Drohnen so billig geworden sind, dass jeder auch über dem Boden der Vereinigten Staaten selber eine hat und dann das da so ein bisschen zurückschwappt.
Also irgendwann wird alle jemand eine haben und dann gibt es keine Soldaten mehr?
Dann gibt es keine Ruhe mehr, glaube ich. Weil die Berichte, die ich da gesehen habe, die Dokumentationen von den Landstrichen, die dort von Drohnen regelmäßig kontrolliert werden, sind schon echt angsterregend. Wenn du einfach ständig über dir irgendwie das fliegende Auge schweben hast, wo du nicht weißt, ob es guckt oder schießt, dann zermürbt dich das einfach. Da zermürbt es auch die Grundpfeiler der Gesellschaft. Und ich denke, das ist so eins der großen Themen für die nächsten fünf Jahre, wo wir uns dann auch mal Gedanken darüber machen müssen, was es so bedeutet, was es bedeutet, autonome Flugmaschinen, autonome Beobachtungsmaschinen, Datenschutzaspekte, da sind natürlich doll spannend. Aber wenn die Dinge dann bewaffnet rumfliegen und nicht mehr zuordnen, wem die gehören, dann haben wir hier als Gesellschaft ein sehr spannendes Thema, dessen wir uns da mal annehmen müssen.
Eigentlich sind es ja fünf Jahre.
Also ich denke, wir müssen jetzt darüber nachdenken.
Bei der gelingen auch mal gleich eine Buchempfehlung von Daniel Suarez, den ja der eine oder andere vielleicht schon mal gelesen hat. Ein US-amerikanischer Schriftsteller mit so Science Fiction, die so in der nahen Zukunft spielen. Er hat ein Buch geschrieben mit dem Titel Kill Decision. Man kann das auch legal erwerben, auf Englisch sogar für einen kleinen Preis. Nur auf Englisch für einen kleinen Preis. Auf Deutsch ist es ja sehr teuer. Wenn es das schon gibt, ich weiß nicht. Auf jeden Fall, das ist ziemlich spannend. Also das spielt eigentlich in der Jetztzeit, aber schon ein bisschen weiter, weil halt überall Drohnen auftauchen und auch in den USA, also in der westlichen Welt, ordentlich rumballern und da geht es eben darum, dass diese Drohnen das eben auch selber entscheiden können, wen sie erschießen. Und das ist schon eine ganz düstere Zukunftsvision, aber sehr spannend geschrieben. Also kann man wirklich zur Einschlaflektur überlegen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, kein wirklich gut geschriebenes Buch, aber eine spannende Idee. Aber wir warten einfach auf die Verfilmung.
Also für die ersten Suarez-Bücher, da Diemen, was ein wirklich sehr lesenswertes Buch gewesen ist, da hat er ja sicher die Filmrechte inzwischen schon verkauft. Und da bin ich immer gespannt, was da draus wird. Anderer Film, der da gerade in der Mache ist, ist ja die Geschichte von WikiLeaks verfilmt. DreamWorks hat da gerade angekündigt.
What?
Ja, ich glaube, Benedict Cumberbatch, der da aus Sherlock auch bekannt ist, der soll bei Assange spielen. Gerade ist der Original-Schauspieler, der Daniel Domscheit-Berg spielen sollte, abgesprungen und Daniel Brühl ist dafür eingesprungen. Und wenn ich die Gerüchtetage richtig verstehe, dann geht es wohl darum, dass die Wikileaks-Geschichte so präsentiert werden soll, dass dort der eine durchgeknallte Typ, also Assange, sich wie diesen armen deutschen Hacker Daniel Domscheit-Berg genommen hat und erst die Kraft der Liebe in Form von Anke dazu geführt hat, dass er dort von diesem verrückten entrissen worden ist.
Okay, die Wahrheit über Wikileaks erfanden wir also nächstes Jahr im Kino.
Ich frag mich...
Warte, ich muss drohen, möchte ich noch kurz sagen. Hatten wir vor nicht allzu langer Zeit eine Chaosradio Sendung? Könnt ihr euch gerne mal anhören, die ist nicht uninteressant. Und ja, was war noch mit dem Film?
Na, ich frag mich mal, wie denn die anderen handeln in Charaktere. Ob dann Kevin Spacey irgendwie Andy Müller Magoon spielt und Maha könnte ja irgendwie von... Ja, genau. Und hier Konstanze Kurz könnte von Sigourney Viva gespielt werden. Da ist ja... da geht was, glaube ich.
Da geht auf jeden Fall was. So, wie gesagt, die Wahl über Wiki liegs nächstes Jahr im Kino. Jetzt kommen wir, nachdem wir die ganze Sendung zurückgeblickt haben, zu einer Vorschau der Kongress. Was? Not My Department, Maha. Du wolltest ja sozusagen genau erklären, was das ist. Oder macht das jemand anders?
Also, Not My Department ist halt ein Zitat. Das ist ein Zitat von Werner von Braun, der angesprochen worden ist auf seine Teilnahme im Nationalsozialismus. Im Besonderen gab es da wohl Leute aus einem Konzentrationslager, die da mitmachen mussten in der Waffenproduktion. Werner von Braun hat auch da Entscheidungen getroffen und hat auch dieses Lager besucht. Und hinterher, als er darauf angesprochen wurde, hat er gesagt, it's not my department. Also er hat dadurch seine Verantwortung so ein bisschen von sich gestreift. Und das ist so ein bisschen die Inspiration eben für dieses Motto, das wir auch haben. Es geht also darum, dass Hacker nicht für bestimmte Firmen arbeiten sollen. Wenn sie das tun, haben sie eben auch Verantwortung. Können die einfach sagen, ich interessiere mich nicht für Politik oder so, it's not my department. Dafür wollen wir halt ein bisschen sensibilisieren, deshalb dieses Motto.
Das hatte dann später Tom Learer in diesem wunderschönen Lied über Werner von Braun aufgenommen, wo er dann gefragt worden ist und der hat dann in den Kontext gereiht, that once the rockets are up, I don't care where they come down, that's not my department. Also solange man erstmal die Raketen in die Luft befördert ist, was ja die Aufgabe eines Wissenschaftlers ist, dann ist mir egal, was dann die Leute, denen man das erfunden hat, damit machen. Und da muss ich dann dieses, keine Ahnung, Department of Conscience und Konsequences mit beschäftigen.
Die anderen. Die anderen TM. Das ist also das Motto des Kongresses. Der ist ja dieses Jahr nicht in Berlin. Weißt du denn das? Das habe ich gehört. Und es gibt noch Karten. Das ließ mich vermuten, es ist nicht in Berlin. Aber wo ist er denn und was passiert da überhaupt?
Dieses Jahr wird der Kongress aus Platz gründen. Und weil wir in Hamburg sehr willkommen geheißen worden sind, genau da hinziehen ins Kongress Center Hamburg, CCH. Was direkt an diesem einen ICE Bahnhof, der von Berlin gut zu erreichen ist, an dessen Name ich mich nicht mehr erinnern kann.
Hamburg Dammtor. Da kannst du also mit dem Bademantel in Berlin einsteigen. Wie Stoiber das mal sagt. Zehn Minuten.
Es ist also in Hamburg, es ist schnell von Berlin erreichbar.
Wir haben dort ein bisschen mehr Platz als in den letzten Jahren. Wir werden schauen, dass wir die Veranstaltung so wachsen lassen, dass es nicht total ungemütlich wird. Wir haben da ja ein Haus zur Verfügung, das wir bespielen möchten, indem wir wieder über 90 ziemlich coole Vorträge auf dem Vortragster-Track, also in drei verschiedenen Sälen, uns anhören können. Und es gibt dieses Jahr das Konzept der Assemblies. Das ist so, wer mal auf dem Camp gewesen ist, das ist so ungefähr wie die Villages. Dass man da so mal... Das sind so kleine Dörfer, in denen sich Leute zusammenfinden, die ähnliche Interessen haben, die an ähnlichen Projekten hacken und die diese gerne präsentieren möchten oder die Gleichgesinnte suchen, um gefunden zu werden. Und da haben sich jetzt auch schon, ich glaube, irgendwie 80 Assemblies angemeldet, die alle ihr kleines Reich bekommen und sich dort zusammenfinden können. Ich bin auf jeden Fall auf dem Kongress, werde da auch einen Jahresrückblick, der vielleicht ein bisschen strukturiert, das heißt die Sendung über den CCC geben. Wir haben dort, ja, wir versuchen, dieses Gemütlichkeitsgefühl, was wir da im BCC in Berlin hinbekommen haben und auch dieses in den letzten Jahren, ob der Tatsache, dass der Kongress so überlaufen ist, gab es ziemlich wenig Leute, die reinschnuppern wollten, einfach nur mal so zu gucken. Dieses Jahr sind einfach noch Karten über und dieses Jahr können einfach Leute vorbeikommen und sagen, ich will mir diesen CCC mal angucken, ich will da vielleicht an einem Tag hin mir mal anschauen, spannende Vorträge, die ich mir vorstellen kann, anzuhören, Fragen zu stellen und danach mich noch mit Leuten, die da auch in dem Vortrag gewesen sind, unterhalten.
Gucken, ob das wirklich so eine Klugscheiße sind.
Aber das mit den Assemblis ist eigentlich eine super Idee. Man kann ja sagen, was ich meine. Also, ich meine, das ist ja immer das Problem in den letzten Jahren gewesen mit diesem Hackcenter. Da war kaum noch Platz und das war überfüllt. Und viele Leute, die gerne was machen wollten, kamen da nicht rein. Und jetzt ist da einfach mal so richtig viel Platz und die Leute können da richtig ihr Zeugs ausfahren und einfach mal zeigen. Also auch so eine Art Leistungsschau.
Eine Chaos-Messe?
Ja, so ein bisschen vielleicht. Aber ich kann mir das super spannend vorstellen, einfach auch um neue Sachen zu entdecken. Das ist für mich ja der besondere Reiz. Ich will da ja irgendwie was Neues entdecken. Das kann man jetzt mal so richtig.
Und nur um das nochmal gefragt zu haben, ich muss kein Ausgleichssystem hinzukommen, sondern es reicht Interesse zu haben.
Das ist ja eigentlich generell die Idee seit immer gewesen. Es gibt diese Berührungsängste, dass hier die totalen Cracks rumhängen würden. Aber das mag vielleicht für einzelne Themen bei den Hackern immer stimmen. Aber natürlich ist jeder einzelne Hacker nicht der totale Auskenn an allen Bereichen und geht genau mit demselben vor, wissen, was eigentlich die Leute da draußen auch haben, in viele andere der dort vorgetragenen Veranstaltungen rein.
Am Tag 3 ist auch Junghackertag. Da gibt es halt auch ein spezielles Angebot für Kinder und Jugendliche, die sich vielleicht das erste Mal überhaupt mit diesen ganzen Themen und all dem auseinandersetzen wollen.
Das erste Mal mit einem Lötkolben.
Ich geh da auch hin. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich da verkleiden muss, damit die Leute mich nicht auslachen.
Du bist ja klein.
Ich kann das ja nicht empfehlen. Im letzten Jahr gab es auf dem Kongress eine Rakete, da konnte man sich bunte Lichter zu, irgendwie noch zusammenlöten, das hab ich gemacht. Das befriedigende Gefühl, selber etwas gelötet zu haben, ist nicht schlecht, ich werde trotzdem nicht die Elite-Löter, aber das mal ausprobieren zu haben, ist schon sehr gut.
Wir hatten ja die Datenspuren in Dresden Ende Oktober, und da gab es ja auch unten im Foyer so einen Junkhacker-Lötwerkshop, und das hat wunderbar funktioniert. Ich denke, dass das durchaus hier auch in meinem großen Stil machbar ist.
Für Leute, die interessiert sind, diese Assemblies sind schon im Internet einsehbar. Es gibt unter events.ccc.de, da ist es glaube ich verlinkt, dann slash congress 2012, eine Liste unter anderem der Assemblies. Man kann sich auch selber dort eintragen. Wenn man daran interessiert ist, kann man es kommentieren. Man kann eigene Assemblies dort noch versuchen zu beantragen. Es gibt immer noch auf dem Kongress selber ein Konzept heißt Lightning Talks. Das sind so fünf Minuten Vorträge, die man selber zu seinem Lieblingsthema halten kann, wenn man meint, dass nicht dort ein ganzer Dreiviertel-Stunden-Vortrag daraus wird, aber man mal grob Updates geben möchte. Die kann man auf der Webseite, das ist ein Wiki, kann man da eintragen. Und Partizipationen ist, glaube ich, dieses Jahr ganz groß geschrieben, dass wir einfach mit den neuen Möglichkeiten, die man da hat, mit dem größeren Gebäude, mit diesem Umzug, mit dem gesamten Gefühl, dass jetzt da mal so einige der Verkrustungen über den letzten Jahren, wo es so eingespielt war im BCC, aufgebrochen wurden, dass dort viele spannende Dinge passieren und wir würden da Partizipationen der Gäste auch wieder ganz groß schreiben.
Also das heißt vor allen Dingen auch das Programm, also die Vorträge sind auch schon festgeschrieben. Da kann man jetzt nicht irgendwie noch einen Vortrag einreichen, außer zu diesen Kurztalks. Aber generell, wenn man noch so eine Idee hat für so eine Assemblite, dass man sagt, hier, ich möchte gerne mit meinem Tisch...
Bis Samstag kann man die noch einreichen.
Diesen Samstag?
Diesen Samstag ist eigentlich offizielle Deadline.
Also übermorgen?
Ich glaube, Bernie verwaltet die und die wird mich gleich hassen. Aber wahrscheinlich, wenn man eine coole Assemblite hat, wird man auch später noch mit ein bisschen betteln und nachrutschen können.
Es gibt auch wieder einen Workshopraum, der sich mehr oder weniger selbst organisiert. Also wer da was machen will, braucht sich nicht zurückhalten. Also auch ohne, dass man einen Vortrag eingereicht hat. Einfach hinkommen und was machen. Also da gibt es genug Möglichkeiten diesmal.
Und beim Hinkommen kann man auch sagen, es gibt auf dieser Seite auch ein Wiki, wo sich Leute organisieren, von wegen Mitfahrgelegenheiten und Unterkünfte und alles Mögliche.
Ja, es hört ein Experiment diesmal. Das muss man auch aus euch sehen, aber ich finde das dafür, dass es wirklich so einen experimentellen Charakter hat. Wir vorher nicht wussten, ob wir die Ressourcen wieder zurückgreifen können, irgendwie zwischen Berlin und Hamburg hin und her zu pendeln. Es ist einfach ziemlich cool gelaufen bisher schon. Ich bin da auch, ich freue mich da schon echt drauf.
Jetzt sagen wir mal das Datum.
Datum von was?
Vom Kongress?
Na das findet so nach Weihnachten vor Silvester statt.
Bis 30. Dezember.
Alles klar. So, dann haben wir es eigentlich, oder?
Na mein Internet ist...
Ihr müsst euch jetzt so vorstellen, Chaos Radio ist immer auch so, die Leute sind immer am Computer währenddessen. Und wir haben hier so ein kleines Vorbereitungsdokument, da können wir alle gleichzeitig drin rumarbeiten. Und da steht jetzt seit Anfang der Sendung, ohne Windows 8-Witz geht es nicht, Windows verstehe ich nicht, Maha hat nur noch eins gleichzeitig, eventuell noch mal Salz. Was zur Hölle?
Na, Microsoft ist ja jetzt mit diesem Betriebssystem da rausgekommen, dieses Windows 8.
Betrübssystem.
Und haben damit eigentlich alle Versprechungen, die sie da mit dem Namen und dem Konzept dort gemacht haben ursprünglich, haben sie aufgegeben. Das ist halt nicht mehr Windows, sondern nur noch ein einziges Window. Also Microsoft Window 8.
Das ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Wenn du nicht da ganz groß drum rumhackst, dann siehst du halt nur eins und darfst vielleicht in der Vorschauansicht eines zweiten Fensters von links da mal reingucken lassen. Mehr ist es auch nicht. Ansonsten haben sie mit diesem Versuch dort mal auf Tablets zu gehen und diese X86er, dieser Prozessor, der eigentlich in allen PCs drin ist, da sich da mal verabschieden, um auch Arms zu unterstützen. Das ist nämlich der Prozessor, der in allen Mobiltelefonen und Tablets drin ist. Haben sie denn auch das zweite Versprechen aufgegeben, was sie bisher Leuten garantiert haben, dass ihre alte Software darauf läuft? Das heißt, mit Windows 8 ist man eigentlich gerade irgendwo so zwischen den Welten, zwischen den Stühlen und ich finde, das sollte man umbenennen in Windows 8.
Aber ist es nicht eh so, dass sozusagen nur jedes zweite Windows benutzbar ist?
Ich benutze schon seit Ewigkeiten, also außer meiner Mama sein Windows. Also ich weiß nicht, meins ist benutzbar, meiner Mama seins nicht und da magste Recht haben.
Aber ich finde das nicht gut, dass es da ein Window heißt, weil wir hatten ja schon immer Ex-Window auf dem Unix-System und wenn jetzt irgendwann Windows nur noch Window heißt, dann gibt es noch mehr Verwechslung, vor allen Dingen, wenn die dann das 10. Betriebssystem anfangen.
Und wenn man nur eins sieht, heißt das ja noch lange nicht, dass es nur eins gibt, nicht wahr?
Genau.
Die verstecken sich nämlich nur.
Fiese kleine Dinger. Markus!
Wir gehen uns hier in Details, die sind schon wieder viel zu groß.
Markus!
Ja bitte, was denn?
Willst du jetzt wissen, was der rote Wolf bedeutet?
Der große böse Wolf, was? Der böse Wolf.
Nein, der böse Wolf hat natürlich das Rotkäppchen bedroht. Und da das heute dem Markus seine letzte Sendung ist. Haben die ihm eine kleine Flasche Sekt einer nicht spezifizierten Marke, die den bösen Wolf vielleicht den grob umschrieben ist mitgebracht. Und noch ein kleines Präsent, ein Geduldsspiel, weil du so verdammt viel Geduld mit uns hattest.
Vielen Dank. Ja, jetzt ist es raus.
Und das hier kannst du dir auch noch selber ergründen. Unser schwarzes Schaf in der Hacker-Community.
Ich bin...
Das werden wir in die Webcam halten, aber die sehen das sowieso noch.
Ich setze mal das scharfe Monitor, wenn ihr auf Fritz in die Webcam geht, könnt ihr das dann noch angucken. In den nächsten 10 Minuten wird das bestimmt noch einmal aktualisiert. So, worum geht's hier eigentlich? Also es geht darum, der Herr Richter macht sich jetzt von dann, ich höre bei Fritz...
Ich geh in die Babypause.
Ich höre bei Fritz auf und werde Mutter. Nee, Quatsch. Und deswegen war das jetzt das letzte Chaosradio mit mir und auch generell wird mich hier nicht mehr hören. Es hat mir viel Spaß gemacht mit euch. Und ich übergebe das Chaosradio zum Beispiel an jemanden, der sich eigentlich noch mal melden wollte heute, aber irgendwie das nicht mehr getan hat. Aber das kennt man von ihm auch schon und man kennt ihn auch schon. Also die nächsten Chaosradios, die euch allen werden, wird ein gewisser Herr Klein moderieren. Der Holgi. Genau, der hat das auch schon mal gemacht. Mit guten Händen.
Um genau zu sein, war meine erste Chaosradiosendung, die ich hier mit bestritten habe, war mit dem Holgi. Da saß ich, glaube ich, mit dem Bert, der jetzt auch gerade neben mir sitzt.
Das waren noch Zeiten. Da haben wir noch die Webcam umgedreht.
Und damals gab es auch... Also die Sendung war, glaube ich, dieses Wi-Fi. Wo muss der hier sein? Total der krasse, heiße neue Shit.
Die Schweine. Jetzt kommen hier Leute ins Studio.
Um Gottes Willen, was passiert hier?
Du kannst seine Daten nicht richtig spüren.
Ich suche für meine Damen und Herren.
Da ist er.
Wir stören nur sehr ungern dieses kleine akustische Tett a Tett hier. Aber es handelt sich hier um einen kleinen Notfall. Herr Richter, ich darf uns kurz vorstellen, wir sind ein kleines Spezialeinsatzkommando.
Mein Name ist Schmidt.
Mit Doppel T. Hallo Herr Schmidt. Sehr erfreut, Ihre Bekanntschaft zu machen. Haben Sie einen Auftrag für mich? Wir sind von einem speziellen Einsatzteam. Wir sind die freien Rächer in turbulenten Zeiten.
Kurz Fritz.
Ich darf kurz vorstellen. Agent SchragEi hier an meiner Seite. Wir haben ebenfalls an meiner Seite Agentin Katzenschmidt. Und nicht zu vergessen natürlich unseren Koordinator Captain Ahab Jonstortier, seines Zeichens Captain der Ushimira.
Herr Richter, unseren Aufzeichen zufolge ist dies Ihr letzter Blue Moon. Sehen wir das richtig?
Das ist mir zugetragen worden, ja.
Das trifft sich ganz hervorragend. Wir haben einen Auftrag für Sie. Wie Sie unschwer erkennen können, sind wir soeben durch einen Zeitportal aus der Zukunft in Ihre Welt eingedrungen. Der Grund dafür ist folgender. Es ist sehr wichtig, in unserer Zeit im Jahr 2112 herrscht Krieg zwischen den Digitalgroßmächten Google und Apple. Aufgrund unzähliger Cyberattacken sind die Datenverluste auf beiden Seiten erheblich.
Unser Einsatzteam hat es sich quasi zur Aufgabe gemacht, einzuschreiten. Aber für unseren Plan, da fehlt noch jemand, der Ahnung hat von diesen ganzen Krämpel. Und deswegen müssen Sie mitkommen, weil Sie sind der Einzige, der noch weiß, wie man Backups macht. Und deswegen müssen Sie sich uns anschließen. Sie haben da keine andere Wahl. Und deswegen sind Sie unsere letzte Rettung, die letzte Rettung der Menschheit. Und deswegen auf ins Demissionsportal.
Ja, liebe Leute, also das ist dann wirklich der Punkt, wo ich einfach nur noch das Terrain hier verlassen kann. Es hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht mit euch.
Der Markus hat Pipi in den Augen.
Ich bin dann mal raus und muss auch ein bisschen weinen und ich will euch aber noch, also bevor die mich hier wirklich entführen...
Herr Richter, die Rückwegkoordinaten sind bereits aktiviert. Wir haben keine Zeit zu verlieren.
Also ich habe dann tatsächlich nur noch eine Sache zu sagen, bevor das Rückwärtskoordinatensystem mich hier mitnimmt, macht bitte immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen. Beeilse sich!
Wir halten uns auf!
Entschuldigung, das tut nur ein bisschen leid.
Und da der Markus gerade schreiend das Studio verlassen hat, muss sich der Erdgeist vom CCC von euch verabschieden. Die nächste Sendung findet am 31. Januar statt. Im Dezember haben wir nämlich ein Kongress und dann mit Holger Klein. Und ich freue mich auf euch.
Ein Podcast von fritz.de